okay it is time for hate reott mail if
you haven't ever heard hatred mail
before it is when a professional deep
voice movie announcer reads the hate
mail that I get hey let's face it the
only logical response to guns is more
freakin guns Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom alright so
some of the themes of hatred mail as
many of you know anti-semitism
xenophobia homophobia and today I guess
we could say it's sort of a homophobia
kind of but also kind of gender
stereotype just kind of like stupid
comments about gender let's take a
listen to it
the Pakman cults I can picture what a
roomful of you would look like sad bunch
drooling over this clown you can tell
Pakman is the preppy narcissist from
back in everyone's school days
he lost his following when school ended
so he turns to the internet to find more
minions he's just a feminine metrosexual
with no real man as followers and this
is where he will fail along with his
aunty foie wenches it's so funny because
we have the opposite problem there's
this very difficult what's the phrase
I'm looking for nut to crack when it
comes to news shows like ours where the
audience is overwhelmingly male to the
point where advertisers know that and
any product that is at least 50%
expected to be marketed to women or any
product that is specifically marketed to
women they don't want to advertise on
programs like ours because the audience
is like 70 to 75% male now I know what
the person saying just because you're
male doesn't mean you're a quote real
man so I get what they're saying but in
reality the problem is there's too many
men in our audience unfortunately we
don't yet have the demographics for how
many of those men are really I know so
we'll have to find
I don't even know how you would check
that but I'm guessing that if we wanted
to hire this hatred to consult he could
help us figure out how do you identify a
real man make hay tree its cry by using
the coupon code hey tree at forty to
sign up for membership you can go to WWE
at medCom pick any membership and when
you check out type in h80
our IOT forty four zero and you'll save
40% off of your membership and seventy
two hey tree 'it's will cry seventy two
hatreds will cry some of you will
recognize where that number comes from